welcome to another ideas that matter
conversation I've got my good friend and
colleague Scott torulli here somebody
who originally started out as a client
and then as we worked our way through
you know studying aerosol's rhetoric and
various other texts we found that we had
so many commonalities and we we wound up
some of you may know doing a classic
metal class for a long time which we
might reprise sometime down the future
now Scott the reason I wanted to bring
him in here for a talk specifically is
He Is We could call an Insider cubed
when it comes to the music business
which has changed really significantly
in you know the last 40 50 years and
especially in the last 20 years and
Scott is a practicing musician has done
that really since
um your teens I think right and so he's
he's seen the industry from that side
doing gigging Studio work playing on
albums uh bat you know uh being in a
number of different bands leading
different bands he's also a professor of
guitar which is kind of a cool thing to
be a professor of at Berkeley School of
Music so he is helping young people not
just in terms of technical proficiency
but also thinking about larger issues
bigger things in scope in the music
industry and of course he's got all
sorts of contacts as well that that we
talk about fairly regularly so he's not
just drawing upon his own experience but
a lot of other people who talk about
similar things and I thought it could be
quite useful to have a conversation
about this and we'll probably stray into
discussing philosophy and other
disciplines and what they might possibly
have to do with music and I do want to
point out at the very beginning that
Scott is doing something new for him but
it's sort of a natural outgrowth of a
long process of development which is
offering mentoring sessions for
musicians who want to step up their game
and figure out how to actually earn a
living in this tough music business so
did I leave anything out Scott that's
particularly relevant or you want to
bring up right away uh no that was a
that was a great introduction and yeah
that's uh it's all we can we can go from
there I think well I think you know
something that might be a good lead-in
um I mentioned that you you teach a lot
of younger people and I think there's
quite a few who have
let's call them imaginary just to be
nice ideas about the way things work in
the music business and part of this is
kind of rooted in the past the way
things used to work a mythology about
that like you know if you just put in
the work and go on tour somebody's gonna
discover you some talent scout and a
record company will you know come up to
you and say we love your work and we
want to make you the next big
solo artist Band Whatever and they think
that like they can accelerate this by
putting their stuff on YouTube and uh
playing in their their bedroom and you
know there are some success stories like
that but those those are the real
outliers right the exceptions that's not
generally how things work and you and I
have talked about this in the past the
music business has become
much more difficult to earn a living in
and to break into particularly as a
young person so it when you have these
crops of of students coming through your
classes semester after semester what
would you say are the biggest
misconceptions that they come in with
that they need to be weaned away from
um yeah so we're talking College age
like 18 to 22
um
and
I think
a lot of this stuff is
what I what I've what I call is uh the
the Silicon Valley message okay you know
um you got a phone you've got you know a
video camera you've got you know uh
Garage Band you got a recording studio
and Bam you're an artist
and um I think a lot of people uh like
we'll use a a buzzword that I think was
is being pushed the where that drives me
crazy which is branding right what's
your brand yeah and
um
and I actually kind of find that a bit
of a weasel word you know because a lot
of times when you know it's kind of like
well you know
when they're asked the question about
like what's your brand you know
really
to decide these things
hastily is kind of a disservice I mean
being an artist is a lifetime
uh
it happens over a lifetime and yeah
you're lucky it doesn't stop so you know
maybe they say what's your brand right
now but
um
it's just in my opinion the opinion that
people could stay away from that I
understand a lot of people wanna
sit in their bedroom and make Instagram
videos and get big that way and I you
know I have a few people that I respect
very much that have done it but
really it hasn't been that many people
that that's happened to
um I cannot translate into so you get
big on Instagram right and you're or
perhaps YouTube and you're putting out
videos and stuff like that is it is it
difficult to translate that into like
getting to go on tour or selling merch
or the things where people actually do
in fact make money in the current music
business I I well there's the potential
but you know I always go back to the
Tracy Chapman thing
um back in the 80s in Boston Tracy
Chapman got discovered by playing in the
subway here
and suddenly in that time everybody had
their guitars out and all the train
stations because they said this has got
to be the formula this is
um and and I do have a lot of former
students that I'll touch base with and
say well you've got a lot of followers
here what is that equated to and
surprisingly most of them are saying
they're not making any money or they got
a free guitar strap
um but the problem is it's
technology moves so fast now and you
know maybe you hit it big at 19 on on a
platform
um I don't know what the shelf life is
is of somebody on there because we're
inundated with so much that's right
there's a lot a lot more turnover right
and so what do you do when you're 21 now
you know there there seems to be this uh
Missing thought of of planning ahead and
I think I when you say wean away from
maybe I'll push them towards uh a set of
skills you can have that you will be
employable for example something is as
simple as being able to read music
um you know uh
I've you know generally a lot of my gigs
don't involve that but I can read so
some of my biggest gigs have involved
they'll say can you read sure and then
I'll end up on the stand you know and
then there's a nice check to follow or
developing your ears or developing
um you know you have a set of skills if
you have a lot of skills you're gonna
work it's not like you don't win
basketball if you can get a layup you're
gonna work you know it's not about you
know all the slam dunking or all that
stuff
um is kind of what I compare it to so I
think and you know the set of skills
meaning uh as an artist too is is
somebody that that wants to write music
wants to uh and I think
I encourage a lot of these people to go
you know Boston has a lot of players out
there but I'm kind of shocked at how few
people that age go out to shows the cafe
society as I call it is still out there
and you know if a student were to go to
a show every night nothing will ever
beat the handshake and I think most
people that will that have ever done
business the second you meet someone and
do the Hang you're at the top of their
list you're no longer a profile picture
that they right right and
um you know I encourage people to go
hear shows go hear it in person the you
know the intrinsic value of being in the
moment with the aesthetic energies of of
the room the musicians for better for
worse and um that's where you're that's
where you kind of meet people and I mean
that's how I did it the internet didn't
exist when I was
you know not for a while when I started
but you know back then it was like well
what's the secret well there is no
secret
I just said yes to one gig and then my
career took off that was it
um so I guess that's a long-winded way
of answering but um I I would kind of
wean them from saying
um that they you know especially if
they're going to go to school for it but
if they want to there's nothing uh I
guess I should say there's nothing wrong
with going on Instagram and YouTube
nothing at all but if if you're not
doing the other stuff if you're not
being part of a scene in a community
um where people trade ideas where people
trade
um recordings that they've you know
that's what we used to do CDs and we
were more well listened back then than
most people are you know in the younger
generation yeah I guess you could say
that
the where people are going wrong is
thinking that if I just do this if I put
all the eggs into this basket then
things will take off for me not
realizing that when things do take off
for the people who are doing that thing
that they're thinking about it's because
they're they've got the connections it's
because they also you know spent time
analyzing what other musicians are doing
and now to switch it let's go back to
the branding thing as you're talking
about that I was thinking about somebody
who's a prime example of a artist who
changed his brand several times one of
the most important and influential
people in heavy metal Ronnie James Dio
because when he first started out he was
a crooner you know in front of a band
that wasn't even remotely connected to
heavy metal and I forget exactly what
name he was Ronnie and the prophets
right so it was like a rock and roll
band and then he's in this other band
elf which has just a terrible ugly album
cover and they essentially if you've
ever listened to them they're they're
okay but they're they're certainly not
great and
um they were kind of heavy metal and
then the band essentially gets poached
by another luminary person Richie
Blackmore who knew what he wanted to do
very Dynamic personality forms rainbow
um takes elf kicks all the other members
out except for Ronnie James Dio replaces
them with some other great musicians
like Jimmy Bain on bass you know
um I think cozy Powell was was at the
start on drums and then now Ronnie James
Dio is doing something different
and this is where like the heavy metal
Persona starts to come in and Dio is
very intelligent and humble and he'll
say yeah I learned about Showmanship
from Richie Blackmore and then when I
was in Black Sabbath and then he goes
and does his solo band where now he
controls all of the elements of it in uh
with Holy Diver coming out I think in 83
and
um he just takes off from there and if
you were to look at Dio in say
2000 or 1990 or 1985 and you didn't have
that whole back story you'd be like wow
this guy was like the heavy metal icon
from from step one but no he was doing
two different kinds of music before that
and had a different Persona a different
stage personality even you know slightly
different uh name I think when he was
with Ronnie and the prophets so you know
if he had branded himself at 19 20 21
and said no no this is my brand I stick
to it then what happens when you meet a
Richie Blackmore who's like hey I got
this idea for a different kind of band
you know we're gonna make history yeah
yeah I mean they would call that a
Rebrand but I think intention is a big
point of this okay I think he's a great
example but I think that stuff happened
organically as he grew as a musician so
you know being open to working with
Richie Blackmore being open
you know and finding out that he has one
of the best voices in that genre you
know yeah you know well he'd be
considered that at least in my book and
I think yeah I mean I was shocked to go
back and hear like he was doing like
doo-wop kind of things right right I
think it was an organic I don't think he
said wait wait a minute he's not like
sitting in a deal headquarters going we
got to Rebrand this and we gotta and I
think we saw a natural progression of
somebody's Artistry you know yeah yeah
it wasn't
um it wasn't made in a lab so to speak
in in his case so I think it's a really
good point yeah but you know again it's
not
I understand what people mean by
branding but it it's a
for whatever reason it's a word that
kind of bothers me because it's just a
tired word now yeah oh it's kind of like
what's your brand and you know I make my
living as a musician but I don't know
how I would answer that what would I say
I don't know what my brand is maybe you
can tell me you know in other words I
haven't
um deliberate that's that's actually a
good point so maybe you can't really
know your own brand
on your own and you need the eyes the
brain of somebody else who's intelligent
who actually pays attention to what
you're doing not just some person coming
in and spending 10 minutes looking at
your catalog from the outside but
somebody who actually knows what you're
doing to be able to give you the answers
to that
yeah you know um there was one class at
Berkeley where they had some uh I think
there was some Executives from Tick Tock
come to speak to one of my classes oh
interesting and it was you know uh I got
to see from
Silicon Valley side and uh about
being very you know they were very kind
of a little a little bit aggressive
about okay you need to sharpen up you
got to do this and you gotta and you
know I noticed everything they said
these weren't artists speaking
um and
I think everything they said
nothing had to do with the art itself
and okay I think
we we all realize that that these people
that run the apps or make a lot of money
off of exploiting people that want to be
famous you know with ad revenue and
stuff and to me it seemed
counterproductive to have somebody come
in and speak about I mean you know
you're students yeah I mean tick tock's
a real thing but you know people talk
about the old and the new oh that's the
old model it's not the old model it's a
model that still exists it's tick tock
is a model yeah yeah uh and and you know
not to put people down that do it
because I would never but it's not the
it's a it's a model it's a way to do it
and
um
if you know it it all I think people
need to really start organizing what it
is what their goal is today for their
future is it
you know you know some people do go on
tour I have a former student that um
she she just did a tour
um with another Tick Tock person and I
don't know what kind of what kind of
shows they were but you know it's kind
of you know I don't know as far as merch
again it's we're so flooded
um I mean when I go through just you
know I'm targeted on social media that
it's always going to be music or it's
going to be gear yeah yeah and I'm
thinking that you know there's only 24
hours in a day and I only have so much
money in my bank account
um so you know if everybody's like well
you just go to this and you make
millions on merch I don't I don't know
of any personal cases like that I'm not
saying it doesn't happen but I don't
know anybody that goes I can retire now
I did Tick Tock and I sold out all my
t-shirts or whatever it seems like
there's there's like a threshold we
could call it a certain tier for artists
and and I think that these are the ones
who get the majority of the attention
and a lot of younger people are like
well I just need to be like them where
they can make it on
um album sales or you know they they can
stream enough that they'll actually make
some money although we'll talk about you
know how streaming has radically changed
the music industry as far as income and
they can sell enough merch and they can
you know headline tours at Arenas and
and bring in a ton of money that way but
they're like probably not even one
percent of one percent of the musicians
who are out there and it's interesting
too because you can say okay well you've
got you've got them and they're you know
really at the top and then you've got
everybody else and everybody else is
just kind of you know Joe Joe blow uh
wandering around doing things and
they're not making it big but a lot of
the bands that we think of as really big
solid well-established artists they're
still struggling I mean I think that
Judas Priest still goes out on tour in
part because they need to make money you
know and the way that you do it is not
through selling albums that much anymore
for them even though they're one of the
biggest metal bands in the world it's
through you know going to
um various uh venues and playing
typically bringing somebody else along
with them who's also kind of struggling
like we've seen Judas Priest with
um Thin Lizzy
um Steel Panther
um Uriah Heap and um Saxon and every
single one of those bands is a a great
band now Thin Lizzy of course is not the
original Thin Lizzy but they're playing
thin Lizzy's stuff and they still do
have one old member Scott Gorham in
there and they sound good but if they
don't get out there they're they're not
you know they they're if they retire
they've got what they've got and that
might not be enough and so I think a lot
of people don't realize that there's the
stratospheric artists who are going to
do great no matter what unless they do
something stupid and get themselves
somehow canceled or something like that
and then there's everybody else you know
including some really solid
well-established 20 albums in their
catalog artists who still have to scrap
by I think you're raising a good point
there in in short there's really no
middle class in music now
um as I put it you know I think yeah
yeah in the 80s if you were really good
and at least in Boston what I saw yeah
you you didn't have to be signed the
clubs were packed and they were there to
see you know you
um and I remember you know being in town
seeing the lines across at all the great
clubs in Boston and you know once in a
while someone would get signed you know
the cars came out of Boston until
Tuesday came out of Boston yeah and um
but for the most part if you know if
these bands worked hard in in uh if they
were good you didn't need the Internet
you know you you know people always say
well how if you don't have your stuff on
Spotify how are you ever heard right you
mean nobody heard nobody heard of
anybody until the internet you know
that's not true I was there
um so I think that there's this thing
that there's not really a middle class
because
on one hand
even people around our age think the
only way to do it is to give the music
away for free which is is a you know I
think if we're calling the devil's
bargain right because you get some
awareness as I think this is the term
that they use right brand awareness
um but you're giving it away for free
and so then how do you get somebody to
actually want to pay for it
well that's it and um I've been somebody
that I sell my music on my website you
can buy physical CD or download and
um you know people give me a hard time
about it and and
um you know that's interesting why do
they give you a hard time about it are
they giving you a hard time because
they're like old man you need to get
with the times Spotify is the way to go
yeah well yeah get with the times is one
and then people ask me something that I
can't understand how do you expect
people to hear you and I and I just say
the same way we heard about everybody in
the 80s and 90s in the 70s you know
um there are people part of the cafe
Society it's not as many you know but
like I go to shows I buy tickets to
local shows and even if it's friends of
mine I'll show up and you you know I
think there's something to be said you
know we could always talk about you know
relationships with other people and
treating people with respect
um but to be part of that is satisfying
for me I'm I do enjoy hearing good live
music you know original music yeah
um yeah so I do I get Flack for it and
um
but I you know I don't need just about
everybody I know I know a few people
that do well very very few maybe one
percent less than one percent but for
the most part the people that have their
stuff on I always find it where that
they're begging for a listen would you
do I played with artists as a guitar
player yeah yeah where they're begging
just when you go stream this song want
just once will you go give me a like and
I thought you know where's your
merchandise where's your you know that's
interesting and part because what that
means is that the Spotify model and
other streaming models uh like apple
music don't really work because if they
did it if the premise is well you put
your music on there people are going to
stream it this is how you get your
um this is how you get
awareness this is how you get some some
traction and then this is how you make
it big and if Spotify won't do that
except for like their super famous
artists then which they have a deal up
front by the way they don't exactly they
don't work for what we work yeah and and
you have to invest your own time and
treasure as they say then it's not as
productive as they they're pretending it
is it's sort of like YouTube I mean
people can getting away from music you
can like create tutorial videos and you
know there's this whole like industry
out there and you can get some ad
revenue from that
um which in in retrospect is probably a
little bit more productive than trying
to go on Spotify right with your music
um but right yeah YouTube isn't going to
automatically catapult your videos up to
the top you have to bust your hump
promoting them in one way or another you
know or pay for it like a lot of people
do that's true yeah yeah and people
America's really counterproductive right
because if the whole goal is for you to
earn revenue and you have to pay to get
eyeballs or you know ears onto your
content then whatever you're paying is
coming out of that and it's coming out
up front well not only that uh so it's
in the I guess let's let's compare two
things people complained about record
companies right they weren't all sleaze
balls people did sign bad contracts
that's true yeah even if it was a bad
contract you'd be given your you know
even if it was 50 Grand up front to make
the album and then you were put on the
road with a label mate that was a
headliner and then there was your chance
every night to go out and you have a 20
000 people captive in the audience yeah
it sounds like a much better deal even
the the bad side of it I mean yes people
owe the record companies money for their
investment if you invest in something
um you want to return my problem is
I have to invest my own money for the
album Spotify is not saying we'll pay
for your album and then we'll stream it
you know you know 10 15 grand let's say
to get an album if you're gonna you know
use musicians in studios and stuff and
that's coming out of your pocket
um
and to put it up for free
is it doesn't seem logical to me now I I
just think the healthiest thing is for
people to step back and go and watch the
language they're using this is the way
the only way no it's not it's a way and
it's legitimate it does exist you know
yeah
um but
I don't I don't use it
um and it's so funny because people send
me Spotify Clips all the time I said I
don't I don't really use streaming and
they think that's ridiculous and I said
well you know
um I still do buy vinyl and um I have
plenty of stuff to listen if I really
need to hear it it's on YouTube
um but you know if it's kind of like you
know you need to learn this song for you
know something or check out this version
that never was never released of yeah
yeah Iron Maiden
um
so I
I this idea of oh so I want to go back
to the the you know people buying
followers like Instagram
it's what I've done is I'll go on people
like this person's got you know an
unthinkable amount of followers but I'll
go to their followers and I'll click the
profiles and as I get 30 in they're all
blank oh bikes yeah so it's a number and
then you you can see the comments are
bot comments like
really awesome cool so cool yeah can't
wait to listen more so and then there's
the other thing which is the the the
middle person and I don't know if you've
gotten this too you probably have for
your channel where
somebody will present themselves in an
email to me saying
if you pay us yeah we're gonna make this
happen but that's kind of a unilateral
contract because I get at least two of
those per week and the biggest one right
now
is
um they're they're telling me that my
videos they start out by kind of nagging
you they're they're like you're not
doing as well as you should be you know
you could be your stuff is great and
you're like you've never watched any any
of my stuff right but they'll come out
with a compliment and then they'll be
like you're only getting this amount of
views on these videos and sometimes
they're right and sometimes they're just
like making stuff up right because
they're not actually checking figures
because that would cut into their their
time and their business model I think is
basically just flood the internet with
this and see who will bite and then they
will say you know your video content
would go really really well on Tick Tock
YouTube shorts and Facebook reels we can
do this for you we'd be happy to do one
for free and then you know it's like a
drug Pusher you get your first taste for
free and then you will charge you for
the rest and I you know given because of
the kind of stuff that I do I'm like
well these people don't know anything
about my channel because most of this
stuff would not make good Tick Tock or
you know
reels or anything like that it would
take it would take a good bit of work to
make that happen and these Schmucks are
not going to be the people to to do that
I've also been getting another kind of
interesting thing that's been in the
last year or so because I do have the
the Sadler's lectures podcast yeah and
they they I and this is like not so much
companies this is people
and they will um
uh first it was when are you gonna have
a podcast we want you to take these
videos and turn them into to podcast
episodes so we could listen to them and
after a while I went back and forth and
I was like okay I'll do that and that
was about five years ago and I've got
about 900 episodes at this point in time
of essentially videos that I took short
videos like 10 to 20 minutes and then I
boost the sound quality take out all the
ums and AHS and filler words and pauses
and places where I say the same word
twice or all that silly stuff right and
um then I uploaded it into SoundCloud
because SoundCloud was what I picked
five years ago to use and in SoundCloud
you can get access to all 900 episodes
and so you know first I was just on
Soundcloud and people are like why
aren't you on Spotify that's what I
listen to you know or they would say
uh Apple music or Google
podcasts or pick whatever else you want
you know and I'd be like how hard is it
for you to listen to something on
Soundcloud but but people are kind of
kind of lazy in that respect they they
want it to be on their favorite thing
and so I found out this very funny thing
um on Soundcloud all 900 episodes or 900
plus are available if you go to any of
the things that pick it up like apple
music or Spotify through the RSS feed
they only store 500 episodes
so a couple years ago somebody was like
not all your episodes are available on
Spotify
and I looked into it and I was like okay
yeah yeah only the latest 500 episodes
are going to be available which you know
for a podcast like mine which which puts
out a lot of content that that's kind of
an issue and it was the same thing
though I was like well if you're
bothered by this it's so so easy for you
to not listen to it through Spotify and
to go to SoundCloud it's you know
basically free and you can listen to
whatever you want to nobody's putting up
barriers or anything but people still
they're so platform dependent
which I guess is a matter of habits or
mindset or something like that they're
like well if it's not on Spotify it must
not be real or you know if it's not in
my preferred listening platform then
then I don't take it seriously you know
that's yeah I mean and I I wanna
also bring in so
I get asked some things you know about
you know well if it's not on if my
stuff's not on Spotify I have to like
say my you know you can't look me up on
Spotify I had to pull my stuff from all
the streaming now people get
you know Layman's or or whatever you
know people that don't know so much that
um
they think you know you maybe you
haven't made it you're not important on
that but the other interesting yeah yeah
which anybody could like you and I can
you know make a crazy song and stick and
Spotify just you know something
ridiculous but the other one is I'm
really surprised at how many people that
are not in the music business will ask
me about American Idol
I say I don't watch American Idol and
they're shocked because they they have
they're under the belief that this is
the best singers in the world this is
the music business
okay and I have to explain well it's a
it's a game show it's basically a game
show where you know people in with sad
stories so you're you get an emotional
attachment to the different people and
you they get emotionally engaged and I'm
not putting it down it's just it's not
uh reflective of
of the Arts of the art itself and no
disrespect to the people that sing on it
I mean there's why not but um I think
we're having a hard time
this just makes me think about the
middle class thing you know
we'll do I'll do shows in town there'll
be two bands on the build the ticket
will be twenty dollars and people will
complain
I'll have what twenty dollars that's you
know you greedy whatever meanwhile they
just go to pay two thousand dollars for
a Def Leppard ticket oh yeah so you know
I'm thinking you know there's absolutely
middle class you're twenty dollars for
my show or you know two bands is way too
much to spend and then of course if
you've ever been to a concert people are
on their phone or too drunk or you know
yeah so it's so for me it's like
what
what's my demographic well it's not Tick
Tock because let's look at the numbers
for what they are less than a third of
America is on Tick Tock that's less than
a third of America yeah and and
uh sixty percent of those people are
under the age of 24.
so we're not looking at I mean if you
look at the numbers for what they are if
you Google how many subscriptions to
Spotify there's not that many I think it
was
80 to 100 million but we have what 350
million people in the country yeah so
yeah you know so if we kind of look at
these numbers I just you know I think
and I always catch Flack for it because
you know I take the extra step to think
about it you and I have talked about how
hard is it to buy from an independent
bookstore well that's the extra step
they don't want to take because they
could get it on Amazon with a click yeah
and have it you know I it's it's
interesting but
for me personally uh I don't want that
to
I don't want that to guide what I'm
trying to do as an as an artist you know
um you know jump on Trends but you know
we know how fast things change and how
things become obsolete so fast I mean
yeah you know like Alvin Toffler has
this term he uses oppsilage which is
obsolete knowledge which you know the
new platform comes out what you spent
two months working on it's in there but
it's it's useless information
and um and
I don't try to then learn the newest and
greatest it's not how I want to spend my
time
um yeah and that's just me but I but I
do think that's a message to people it's
like hold on a second
it's not the way it's a way you do have
a choice in the matter you know now that
is really important this gets to some of
the stuff that you and I have studied
over the years and that I think uh ties
in with the the mentoring so if like you
said if if it's not the way but multiple
ways now you're faced with the problem
of
figuring out which of these is the
better means to the end that you want to
attain which is like being able to I
mean some people might be like Fame and
Fortune right but maybe let's be a
little bit more moderate being able to
make a living doing the kind of thing
that you want to do creative activity so
this could be the music business but
this could equally be Visual Arts or
other things as well and so when you do
have to make decisions a lot of people
get kind of worried about that and they
would they would really prefer if there
was just one way so they don't have to
do the sorting through an uncomfortable
um you know sometimes anguished work of
deciding what what's going to be their
priority but if you want to be
successful you do have to
um think these things through it's what
we call practical reasoning right
reasoning about practical matters and
people are willing to do this with you
know financing a car
but
um which you know they're only going to
have for five ten years but they're less
willing to do that I think with their
whole life you know to sort these
matters through and I think another
thing is
part of what we're saying here is it's
really important to be brutally
realistic not like Doom and Gloom and
everything is a catastrophe and we'll
never make it but to understand the
difficulty I mean when I in the past I
don't apply for full-time academic
positions but when I did in philosophy
say you know 10 up to about seven or
eight years ago every time I would apply
there would be 300 to a thousand
applicants for any given job now that
means odds are low that I'm even getting
into the first step of interviews and if
I pretend to myself oh if I if I just
believe or you know maybe if I got on
Tick Tock I mean that wouldn't help with
Academia
um you know that'll give me an edge or
what if I like send a nice fruit basket
to these people or something like that
you have to be honest with yourself
about
the odds uh and the fact that you
there's many factors outside of your
control that you don't know and that
that you can focus on the things that
actually are in your control so you know
whether you practice or not if you uh
allow yourself to get down and you're
like well what's the point in practicing
either they're gonna find me and they're
going to like me or they're not and
you're not a punk band uh where lack of
practice could actually be you know for
some people a draw right but you're
doing any other genre
um you you'd better practice and
practicing won't automatically lead to
success but it's a you know it's a
necessary condition for having success
and there's all these other things that
are that are necessary conditions as
well and you know I think when you and I
studied a lot of the stoic stuff it it
really gave me a foundation to what I've
kind of always believed but couldn't put
into words oh interesting the basic
premise
that I got out of it the first thing is
you actually don't have control of very
much yeah maybe maybe how you look at
things but
um I'm constantly asked
you know you know by younger people
you know what's the secret just give it
to me just just give me the prescription
and the pill I'll take it and the the
yeah the truth is there's no formula
there's it's so far out of your control
and I mean you know to the point where I
do know some of the most negative
no-show flaky people that step onto
major gigs all the time and they would
be this person would or these people
would be not this person these people
would be a recipe for what not to do but
what are you gonna say
but then you have the people
put in you know it always bothers me
when people say and I accomplished this
and it was entirely due to my hard work
and dedication
and I think it's good that there's hard
work and dedication
um maybe it factored in but I don't
think we'll ever really it's like an
actors the the Will Smith saying I'm
famous because there wasn't a day in my
life I didn't think I wouldn't be yeah
well you tell that to the thousands and
thousands of you know people serving
coffee in New York City that wanted it
more than you
and you know that was like in the 90s
was Zen in in the music everybody read
the Zen In The Art of that was a thing
and now it's putting it well it's been
put into the universe but
um
I encourage people to let that go and
it's an awful lot of pressure to put on
if I do this because if you expect
something to happen and it doesn't
that's going to lead to indignant
thoughts you know where somebody gets
something that you think you deserve
Envy you know yeah yeah it was supposed
to work out this way why did it work out
for this person because you didn't you
didn't approach the situation
with the right mindset which well that's
the thing any one of these systems and
its proponents always have that out so
you know they'll say well these are the
10 steps you need to do and the person
does the 10 steps and then things don't
work out for them and they're like well
I don't think you really did step eight
right you know your heart wasn't in it
and that's why it failed try again with
with doing step eight better I know they
do it you know they still fail and
they're like well I think the real
problem was we got to go back to the
beginning look at step one you I don't
fully understand and and you can do this
game with people forever you know you
didn't work the system properly as like
the Mantra that's yeah that's so true
and that was the thing with um
what was the book The Secret and it said
repeatedly wishing that it will happen
oh
I was always shocked at the amount of
people that said this is the greatest
book ever written because
I think all of us have had Daydreams
about a lot a lot of things that never
happened right you know and then to say
well people people on Wall Street know
about the secret do they is that what
they're doing at Wall Street they're
talking about the secret you know and
you know they're talking about the book
they read that made them in the position
that they're at and it's kind of but
the fact that so many people grabbed
onto it as
well this is easy all I have to do is
believe and it'll happen and again
that's you're not taking a step back and
thinking it through
um yeah you know like you mentioned you
mentioned stoic philosophy is helping
with some things and you and I have
spent a lot of time talking about and
studying Aristotle as well
um were there other
um
movements schools thinkers that you
encountered that you're finding are
helpful not just for you but also like
you're introducing your students to in
bite-sized pieces
I think also another one that um
that I got really interested in I think
you remember
um oh come on I'm free it's it's the
start it's the lecture the sart lecture
oh existentialism
existential but the book I'm forgetting
it's the existentialism is a humanism by
by start yeah now even even just the
basic sound bite version of it is
interesting you know
um
you're born and then you become
you know some people say I was put on
the earth
um
I think you know it kind of balances
with the stoicism where I look you don't
have
control of much
but maybe the parts you have control of
are talked about by start you know
um where I forget the line exactly but
it's basically you
creation precedes purpose
and yeah or he puts it in terms of
existence precedes essence that's you
decide what your essence is going to to
be and I think you're right there are
there are interesting overlaps when we
look at what we call philosophies as
ways of life and so various kinds of
existentialism stoicism Aristotle's work
understood in the right way
um and there's many others out there the
what they're getting right tends to be
saying similar things not exactly the
same thing because there are some
differences they're saying similar
things
um in different contexts right so
thinking let's go back to like the
thinking about what would you like your
life to actually look like in terms of
being a musician who can earn a living
and practice your craft with you know
some some level of freedom from
interference of some you know executive
telling you I want it more poppy you
know or and yeah at one point if I
remember right in one of our
conversations you had a client who
wanted some music and they said
something to you like
I think it needs to be more orange and
you were like
what the hell does that mean and then
you gave him something and he was happy
with it you're like here's the orange
version but producers I've run into that
a lot where it's you know or even I
think the the story I also told was I
had this one session that drove me crazy
usually you show up you listen to the
track once and they go give me kind of
an a Nile Rogers thing from Chic and you
know what that sounds like or yeah Andy
Summers from the police that's but this
guy kept saying I need the flavor I need
some of the flavor
and I said well is it Motown flavor is
it you know and you know I was but it
gets frustrating because either they
don't know what they're trying to say or
they're poor communicating I mean just
because you have the role of producer
doesn't mean you're good at it right
right I remember that session being
challenging because I was getting
frustrated at throwing things out no no
no not that and then you know
on this session it was you know still
CDs I said will you pull out a CD and
give me an example of a guitar player
playing what you want me to play
they couldn't find it you know finally
just whether you liked it or not he
agreed on something but yeah like you
know exactly it's kind of like so
abstract it's kind of like I have to
figure it out yeah so sort of likes to
Circle back so being able to be a
musician as part of your life how you
earn your money being relatively free of
of crazy people that are putting weird
restrictions on what you're gonna do
that requires
um means and reasoning because you've
got an end you've got a Telos as we
would say a purpose and it's and it's
one that is you know
it is individual to the person but it is
also something that we can generalize
about you could say if you want to be a
musician just going back to the practice
thing you will not be able to develop
the skills that you need without a
regime of practicing right and even
after you've become big you still have
to practice because you don't want your
skills to decline right and practicing
yeah and practicing could include
developing your Artistry exploring the
instrument you know like anything uh you
know because practicing a lot of people
you've heard of that like you know if
you learn music theory you've ruined
your creativity
and you know my company now that is an
interesting thing to bring up and I I
imagine to a lot of listeners that would
be a surprise to hear
why would people in the music industry
be telling you that learning learning
something theoretical about the basis of
this thing we call music which includes
like what sounds can go with each other
into chords or arpeggios or how to shift
from one key to the other why would that
be a deficit why would that get in the
way of being a good musician that seems
counterintuitive it's a it's a buzz word
for people
um you know people Pride themselves of
the self-taught thing Well everybody's
self-taught if I sit down and I show uh
they are because even if yeah all my
students I don't show them the same
exact thing but there's fundamentals we
work on but how come they all sound so
different when they use them because
it's up to them to process this
information in a creative way and my
other thing is if you're a creative
person no matter how many tools are in
your toolbox you're are still a creative
person so I don't I don't understand how
it would stifle creativity unless your
mindset stifled you but having more
tools if you're creating right to go oh
this is interesting so I could do this I
suppose and I could pull this from here
because there's when you're learning
theory there's a misconception that it's
like we're telling you what your can and
can't play well that's not true
um you're you're developing your ears
you're developing you're getting
yourself more tools so when you you know
you're putting this together you're
putting it together like you that's why
I don't mind if you know I don't yeah
well a lot of times when I hear a player
I never go I don't know if you know if
they studied super hard for years or it
was just you know somewhat natural
because they heard albums it doesn't
matter it doesn't matter to me and you
know it's like when people find out like
oh reading music's gonna take away well
how can it take away anything I don't I
mean yeah I mean you have the ability to
sight read now your Cree it's not like
you're suddenly non-creative you have to
re to get rid of this part of your
intellect or your energies to be
non-creative do you think that like the
Trope that a lot of people use which
doesn't actually appear to have much of
a basis in the science at least in its
generalized thing of right brain versus
left brain you know like I'm a
right-brained person this person's a
left brain person and you know you don't
want to like mix up the the creative
part and the logical part because they
they're sort of like oil and water I've
always thought that that sort of
dichotomy was silly and
I didn't I didn't take people seriously
who would who would you know articulate
the world in that way do you think that
that sort of simplistic thinking leads
to this idea that if you're bringing
structure if you're bringing skills that
somehow that gets in the way of genuine
musical creativity
no and I used I I I've always used this
comparison
um at one time I was maybe no we're
going back 25 plus years
I was relatively fluent in Spanish but
believe me those Spanish classes were
brutal and remember the the labs like
you had to do Labs twice a week with it
and that was like these are the verbs
this is how you conjugate them but after
a while I you know like you and I are
speaking if somebody came up and said
excuse me gentlemen
um what were the adverbs and the
adjectives you use that past sentence
was there a dangling participle well we
go what are you talking about
because we're this is something you know
we learned how to speak English but if
say we worked really hard on the second
language and it became fluent you're not
thinking of the initial stuff that you
studied right speaking in your own way
we all we we talk about doing imitations
of people not just how they but the way
they speak like take Christopher Walken
is a great one how he enunciates is uh
you know you can imitate people because
we have our own way of speaking even
though the English language is what it
is and we you know so I think learning a
new language is a perfect thing because
music is a language that's processed by
the language part of the brain I know a
lot of people think it's mathematics
um but I never understood that argument
especially if you're improvising you
know yeah
um we're improvising now you know and
we're we have command of the language
enough if you were to start talking
about giraffes I could take that left
turn with you and start talking about
giraffes you know with the mathematics
thing so you can say that music is
mathematizable in the sense that like
it's all sounds right we can represent
them with waves as you know it's what we
do and we're producing things and we're
looking at the sound waves and tinkering
around them and using effects and you
can express the relationship between
notes that are on a page that you're
reading whether it's in you know actual
musical notation or tablature you can
you can express that mathematically too
but that doesn't mean that music is
mathematics just because it can be
mathematized and there's going to be all
sorts of other dimensions to it that are
going to require
you know other matters to be we could
say blended it right and like in when
you talk about like serious classical
composition if you're looking at 17 to
18th century there's um
there's a bunch of rules like when you
study it but I don't but I don't
consider that mathematics I consider
that more like
uh computer programming which I did as a
youngster that's much more creative so
in other words here's the end result you
need to write a uh uh a number guessing
game on a computer now if you're given
that excitement we knew how to program I
bet you are we would have different our
our um what do you call our programs
would look different because you would
arrive to the at the end yeah there
isn't just one single way to solve the
the right concrete problem put in front
of us even with mathematics like I I
imagine in math in in college and I was
a big skip stepper you know which my
teachers in like K through 12 hated and
they'd get on my case about it and then
when I got into college they were like
hey you want to skip steps go right on
ahead you know there's different ways of
arriving at the right answer
um of course if you make a mistake along
the way we can't figure out exactly
where you went wrong but that's on you
buddy right I could kind of like
visualize where we were going and I and
I did you know generally skip steps no
sometimes that did get me into trouble
if I forgot like to bring a negative
sign in and then I'd get the wrong
answer at the end right but um you know
the different people in in the class
would arrange problems in in different
ways and I think with mathematics is a
great example because people do think
that like there's one single way if
there's anything that we know for sure
it's mathematics but even with that no
there's there's different ways of
working at stuff what's the difference
between arithmetic and math mathematics
right arithmetic is different you know
um mathematics is I remember the guy in
college he was like one of four people
working on some problem which means
there's not a one way to answer what I
mean it was beyond me he kind of on an
office hour he would kind of said he was
working on this thing I'll never forget
oh wow that's like
it is kind of endlessly and creative to
like you know
um
start here and you need to end here and
whatever happens in between is on you
this is the impression I got from from
what he was talking about
um but yeah you know to go back to the
structure creativity thing and to bring
this into philosophy
um and you know also to tie it into your
your mentoring
um program that you have now so I think
that maybe some people have a similar
attitude about philosophy they're like
well I don't want to like re-spend a lot
of time reading these texts because then
people are going to be telling me
exactly how I need to think and I want
to be a bit more you know loosey-goosey
creative man and they don't realize that
hey you can you know nobody's telling
you when you read stoic philosophy that
you have to become a stoic you can learn
from it right and take what you you want
just as much as like if you were going
to listen to I don't know you're going
to pick some some guitarist uh and let's
not pick somebody who's who's well
actually let's pick somebody who's dead
because then at least the catalog is
fixed so fast Eddie Clark you know you
want to you want to learn to play like
uh fast Eddie Clark who is uh most
famous for Motorhead but also Fastway
and has kind of a cool sound you know to
to his stuff it's quite identifiable if
you like listen to his stuff and you
even like pay close attention to it and
you try to follow along you get like the
music and you learn his solos that's not
going to make you only be able to play
like Fast Eddie Clark any more than
studying Aristotle is somehow going to
like put these blinders on you and now
you have to uh look at everything
through the lens of Aristotle's
philosophy although it will be helpful
in a lot of cases you know like some of
the concepts we've already looked at so
far like thinking about what end you
want to attain and then
considering what means and what needs to
be a priority and whether there's
multiple means to get to that end
Aristotle can help you with that stoics
can help you with that you know I mean
Aristotle
um may give suggestions or this The
Stokes may give suggestions yeah
um I I don't remember in in the
Aristotle reading a bullet point
checklist
of you know like like the big thing
the stuff I enjoy most of the rhetoric
was
um you know the emotions and how anger
works because
you know and this is something I use
with my students a lot I I don't go
Aristotle said but
um
I think in you know
giving the list of at the right time at
the right person to the right degree all
that but also
you know the three basic things that
make people angry
if
because it's going to happen you know
especially in this business or or you
know to add on or perceived contempt
well even if that contempt wasn't given
if you perceive and I think it's
important for all of us if we get angry
we have to know really why we're angry
and that
I think the Aristotle was instrumental
in me going wait a minute I thought I
was mad at this that's not true if you
at the beginning it actually ran the the
the things and go now it's it's not that
or I got mad because that was just
spiteful right that was just you know
they didn't gain anything from that you
know or but after a while
the more and then you know it also helps
you be compassionate to others where
it's like well wait a minute
I need to understand why they're angry
even if they don't know you could kind
of say well I think it was probably this
um and that comes to the relationship
part you know when I Mentor I really
talk about
relationships of any kind you know when
you're banned
um and you know if you can
I think we all could you know we we all
are could be protective of our art and
then when you're in a band and it's a
democracy
um you know you you might start thinking
a new way to handle a situation
um with with even just that bit on anger
with yeah and and it's helped a ton and
I think and I have some students
actually
uh two students
um that are that are off doing big
things now
I remember early on because I was at
Bertha I was doing the mentoring stuff
because you know it wasn't just skills
and everything I said you know I brought
in the word magnanimous the way that we
talked about it yeah the different
reasons I said but in your case
you know when you're you're gonna be
held to a different standard so you know
when you get you know if if you do start
touring and people
um you know start even having you know
parasocial relationships with you and
you're at a venue yeah
um but
you know navigating
um
you know be being kind to them because
um you know of course boundaries rather
than dismissive right or rather than
yeah we always go back to the deal thing
I learned what not to do from Richie
Blackmore yeah and Geo was somebody who
um
you know he he related to the audiences
he would say things like I'm so happy to
be here with you
and it comes across as real whereas with
like a lot of bands they're like you
know it's like insert blank here how are
you doing block block block you know and
they're like looking down Chicago
Cleveland you know and uh is everybody
feeling good tonight with Dio if he asks
how are you feeling you actually felt
like he cared about how you were feeling
uh and that and that isn't a parasocial
relationship where how could he possibly
relate individually to every single
member of the audience you know but you
but I always felt he was sincere you
know yes no
um like he would he like one time it was
he was doing don't talk to strangers
and then he says don't talk to strangers
and he he put the mic out and everybody
shouted the last thing he goes you get
it right every time and it's just like
like you know you know we're just like
you know um
and you know
I always found him to be sincere and
well I guess it goes to show we know the
story about when he went back to that
place where was the where was the
country that he was in where he said
we're setting up tables and these kids
took buses they're gonna miss or train
right and yeah very years earlier with
Blackboard who just walked past the mall
well you know we we saw something like
this and you've heard me tell this story
before but I'd be interested to hear
your reflection on it so we went and saw
a kiss who by this time were like a
massively influential band at live at
Letterman back in the early 20 odds and
um you know in New York it's very
difficult for a band to get away because
of the architecture without like having
to be encountering some fans whereas
like in in other places the band can
like go out the back door right to the
boss and so anyway people are all
waiting outside to like you know say a
few things shake hands get autographs
and all that and it was really
interesting because there were four
different limos for the four different
band members and three of the band
members hung around and like
chit-chatted not for like you know 20
minutes straight or anything like that
um and you could say well you know Eric
Carr and Tommy Thayer they're they're
not fully members in the same way that
the original you know people they
replaced are but they hung around and
and you know Tommy Thayer's been with
them for what 20 years you know and so
it's not like he's just Johnny come
lately and he's not a star in his own
right and he's signing autographs and
smiling and stuff like that Paul Stanley
hung around and he's doing that the one
person who like put a towel over his
face so he didn't have to see anybody
and went immediately to his limo Gene
Simmons and people were trying to like
you know say hey Gene could you sign any
he just like wouldn't even engage at all
and we were like yep that kind of shows
you something now it could have been
just an off night but I kind of get the
idea that that's the way it typically
works you know I you know I it's so
funny because
um
a friend of mine
you know I went to see Night Ranger a
few times okay
maybe about 15 years ago
um
out comes Brad Gillis Jeff Watson
and you know everybody's and they're
hanging out it's like you know and um
it's the first time I met Brad Gillis
and um I met him at Nam a few times
really nice guy you know and um they
they were just out there signing
whatever you wanted and if you wanted to
chat and it was you know we're talking
two guitar players I respect a lot that
I grew up listening to those night range
records yeah
and
the first running with Jack blades is he
comes out with a tell over his head with
three escorts oh like this and you know
nobody was rushing him yeah but a few
people like you said were saying you
know hey Jack uh
you know we assigned you know but you
know he wasn't going to be bothered
maybe an off night and then my friend
and I went again
years later and a friend of mine was the
guitarist that replaced Jeff Watson and
um so he got us kind of back to hang out
and
everything's going great Kelly kiege
always looked like the sweetest guy the
drummer the singer what a nice guy we're
talking to everybody
and
I guess it was part of the meet and
greet and Jack blades goes why don't you
just get in the picture come on you know
and then he's like this they take the
picture and he he runs off
and um
you know it's kind of interesting it's
it's like um well that's that's twice
now you know where where it was you know
and I'm is that enough to constitute a
pattern is the question right yeah but I
mean
I can understand if
you know you get the drunk guys laying
into you and you know
I you know did this and I had my first
date to assistant Christian and you know
I can understand yeah that would get old
pretty quick that would get old but like
nobody was doing that you know
um so uh but I think you know the Gene
Simmons one is interesting
um I think a lot of them when you I met
some people that were my heroes that
turned out to be
great zero yeah
I was gonna say uh the contrary to be
heroes who are zeros right yeah and and
um but that's what I was good to go back
I I discuss and
um
they'll text me every once while my
former students I'm being magnanimous
they remember them interesting and
because I because I said this is a big
word and I kind of EX you know I said I
can't barely like you said I can barely
pronounce it yeah I even got tripped up
on it every once in a while
but it's this kind of thing that like
it's this mindset you should have that
you know with good boundaries in place
that you know if you're a little tired
it's okay to take a picture with someone
that yeah bought the ticket or drove
maybe three hours and bought a hotel
rented a hotel room just to see you play
it's not much for you to shake hands and
have a short conversation about your
gear yeah yeah and um I like this idea
actually so for for those who are
watching or listening and don't know
what we're referencing so magnanimity is
translated as great soldness is a virtue
in Aristotle's virtue ethics and it has
to do with how you how you
um deal with people giving you or not
giving you honor or respect or however
we want to frame it and the magnanimous
person the reason why this applies to
rock stars is
they are a person who deserves a lot of
honor and they do demand it but they
don't demand it from people who are kind
of lower than them they demand it from
their years and they demanded from other
people and with people who are lower
they're they're easy going they're
they're willing to engage with them and
it's opposed to being vain on the other
side we were like yeah I'm so much
better than everybody else you have to
give me honor where you don't actually
deserve it and then being
um self-deprecating you know being small
sold as Aristotle says like if you're a
big deal then you get to behave as a big
deal but there's a right way to behave
as a big deal that still preserves these
these you know human relations and like
you said it can take the concrete form
of saying to yourself yeah this this uh
couple probably drove from you know this
other city and it you know they're not
demanding like I hang out with them in
their hotel room you know or sign their
you know their infant's forehead or
something they're just looking for a
little interaction with me and they were
good enough to come to my my show these
are and it represents sort of proper
perspective and I think that this is
this is a great example for showing how
ancient philosophy properly understood
thought through and then applied within
the scope of something very very
contemporary you know the rock and roll
scene in the 2020s can bear incredible
fruit you know
yeah no I and um
and it just it just kind of goes better
because I know
um
I even know some some former students
that met some of their Heroes and it
didn't go well oh yeah and um and I
asked one person and I said well you
know how you doing with that well I have
a hard time listening to those records
anymore
and uh interesting you know I had that
you know I've had that too before
um
with the way somebody acted in a concert
I won't mention the name but yeah the
well-known person I shouldn't have
mentioned the Jack Blade's name I don't
know um now is it because you expected
better so like I was just thinking like
we talked about Richie Blackmore Richie
Blackmore is known for being a jerk and
you know being tough on his band mates
firing people really easily scowling as
he's looking at the crowd like not
cooperating with the we're all here to
have a good time kind of thing right so
if Richie Blackmore you meet him let's
say you get a backstage pass and you
walk in and you're like oh Mr Blackmore
I love your stuff you know for him to
say buzz off kid wouldn't be a surprise
right but if it's somebody else who has
a more cheery Persona that's it
um maybe it would be a surprise well
that's so funny that you say that
because in college my friends and I used
to do
um this this the these these skits we
would make them up differently but like
if you walk in and I'd like be flicking
my hair around and like whatever kid and
so we we call it the 80s attitude okay
so you know we used to kind of do these
but like you know we thought at the top
of the pyramid was Yngwie Malmsteen and
oh yeah and and we love ingvay we love
his music and we kind of all agreed that
if we met him and he kind of pushed us
aside said whatever kid we'd be like oh
my God that was awesome it's kind of
like the Beavis and Butthead like when
Todd would run over their bikes and he
thought like Todd would you know Todd's
so cool yeah like you know if anything
turned out to be nice to us I mean he
did actually I I met him just once uh
you know and he was really nice he was a
really nice guy but like we have to used
to have the signal like the the goal was
to be inve and yeah and you would expect
it from actually in a in in a good way
where you know you have the kind of
sense of humor to go I've you know now
my life is completing days like totally
brushed me off like
but he's you know in real life the the
one time he met him he was just shook my
hand you know pleased to meet you and
that was it and uh but that's really
nice to hear yeah yeah I think
um
but I think that you know the other
person it was a shock it was a shock and
um it was you know even kind of the
point where it's like he he knew he he's
like you know that he was
saying such
not great stuff that he said it's been
an hour you can't get your money back
now
oh wow I know and um that is so cynical
you know it is dark yeah yeah and it was
just kind of like you know people were
walking out people were booing and um
but let's just say his behavior was the
antithesis of any of the lyrics of any
of his songs like the interesting so you
know and I have to admit it's been hard
for me to listen to his music because
it changes what we call an ethos right
and this is something that we studied in
in Aristotle ethos means character and
you present a certain character through
your music
and if it doesn't map on to what your
let's call it your your actual personal
character is like in your interactions
with fans then there's going to be kind
of a dissonance or disconnect there
yeah that's actually perfect yeah
because
um you know you also I think we talked
about this you feel betrayed because
um
well we did that whole episode on you
know uh bands doing 10 farewell tours
you know and
I think
if there's an ethos going on and then
you turn out not to be that you feel
lied to I mean right Aristotle now I
mean this person doesn't know you but
you know you feel kind of lied to maybe
maybe like
I felt you know that it was contemptuous
in the sense that I didn't matter I'm
here to yeah I'm here to like be grumpy
and you know piss you off and then like
go as far as to say you can't get your
money back it's been an hour
you know and I'm thinking
wow like um it's hard to take it
personal because he doesn't know who I
am
you know but I think that's I think most
people would take it personal though
quite exactly yeah I mean I mean it was
it us that was discussing the unwritten
contract you have with your audience I
was just thinking about the term trust
right when you so let's let's take the
issue of the farewell tours
um when you say we're gonna have a
farewell tour and this is this is the
point that D Snyder was making and
criticizing them there's a whole bunch
of things that the fan base the audience
is trusting like this is the last chance
I've got to see these people
um the merch that's from the tour is
going to be kind of unique and I need to
get my hands on that to show support
and this is the last opportunity you
know for for
um they might do solos or something like
that uh on their own but this is the
last time to see this configuration of
the band and then when they decide to go
back out on tour especially if they're
not like acknowledging their fact that
they've already done a farewell tour
which I I think is the case for some of
the bands like kiss and Motley Crew and
uh Ozzy you know as well
um it does show contempt for the fan
base it's like you're a bunch of suckers
you know you're there for me to exploit
and lie to and if I change my mind about
the farewell tour thing I'll just start
up again you know
um yeah no in yeah that was a big thing
about the um
foreign
ERS we wouldn't be number one if it
wasn't for you our fans you know we owe
it all to you our fans yeah yeah and
then I guess when it comes out that
somebody's been
not so sincere with you
and you know you go back to the people
that like I always go back to the jean
jacket right you know got the Triumph
patch of movies in our day was like you
know kiss and but you know these people
were emotionally invested in the music
that's right yeah and then there's there
it is a parasocial relationship
um so it's perhaps governed by some
other Norms let's say than a truly like
friendship relationship but there are I
think there is uh like you said an
Unwritten contract
uh with the fans
you know you're there to do something
for them they expect I mean imagine like
if you got on stage and you're supposed
to be you know a metal band like let's
say take Raven right yeah so Raven still
tours around they're they're still
putting out great music imagine if like
you go to a raven show and you're like
oh man I'm gonna hear Seek and Destroy
and you know all these other things that
I really like and they're like tonight
we are playing
um
show tunes
there'll be metal show tunes but it's
all show tunes you know you'd be like
what the hell you know and it might turn
out to be good but it's definitely not
what you came there for and and you'd be
rightly ticked off
that's a really fascinating point
because you know um
the only time I don't agree with that
this this goes back to the 80s Linda
Ronstadt it was a huge thing she came to
this place called Great Woods which is
in you know the outdoor venue in
Massachusetts sold about 3 000 maybe 10
000 but um
she had a new album and it was all kind
of as I remember like Latin Bossa Nova
and yeah she reinvented herself a couple
times yeah and so when people bought a
ticket they were you know everybody was
walking out because she only played the
new album okay and so
I my thing is well if an artist is
coming on the road you should listen to
the new album they should be wearing a
new album but you know if it was just
thrown upon you like uh you know you go
to see Raven and there's nothing on it
well now we have the internet to look oh
the reviews have been great well tonight
you have the rare treat of seeing us do
show tunes you know um you know that's
kind of uh
yeah I don't know if
there'd be an interesting argument or
the discussion about
can you do that at that level like if
they wanna
it looks like Jeff Tate did that Cabaret
thing I don't know if you remember no I
I it was crazy but like you know if he
went out and did it you knew what you
were buying a ticket for okay no
um but I don't know you don't have how
much
if you're a big star with a Die Hard
fan base how much creative
license do you have unless you're known
for being completely off the wall yeah
you know like so a case in point Primus
right super into Rush the we saw Primus
about a year ago and
um I think it might have actually been
called the farewell to Kings tour
and they they began with playing some
other you know classic stuff right yeah
and then the the second half of the show
and it was a long show they just
basically like marched their way through
farewell to Kings and uh you know
everybody liked it I think but it was
you know if you if you didn't know what
was going on you'd be like what the hell
is this
yeah well you know and another one I
remember do you remember uh
you know if there's metal heads out
there the the Iron Maiden album a matter
of life and death yeah
now I love this that they came out and
did the entire record
and then they took a break and then did
like five of their bus plays or six of
their bus plays yeah yeah
um there was a lot of backlash to that
interesting but I'm thinking you know
how many times can you hear the live
after death set I mean it's a great
album you know
um and I think it's well within an
artist's rights to play their music out
you know
albums supporting the new album is on
par now the farewell with Kings is kind
of random you know uh I I would have
probably dug seeing them do that yeah it
was it was great it was a fun show it
was also one of the weirdest audiences
that we saw I think Primus tends to
bring that that out you know and
actually going back to something else
and we do have to wrap up pretty soon
um something I I thought about very
early on in our conversation
um with with going to shows right so
something that's different from when we
were young like teenagers and and 20
somethings and going to shows now is
that um you mentioned people like being
on their phones and some people are
recording with their phones and I think
yeah okay kind of makes sense they want
to memorialize it there's also a lot of
people just like doing random crap on
their phones but the thing that I find
the weirdest
and it's not just a a young people thing
there's lots of older people doing this
as well is it seems like whatever show I
go to there's a constant stream of
people that can't sit still and watch
the show usually they're like going up
to get beers you know and they'll come
back they can usually only buy like two
at a time two cans of beer and they you
know they're leaving like in the middle
of a song not like in between the bands
right the opening band and the the other
band they're you know like a great song
will come on and then you see them get
up and they're like walking off towards
the back and and getting themselves
something now maybe some of them are
going to the bathroom and couldn't hold
it or something that's understandable
but a lot of times they're coming back
and they've got their two big cans of
beer in tow and it'll only be like 15 20
minutes before they manage to slam those
two which they paid a ton of money for
right and then they're back walking
again and you're like didn't you come
here to see armored Saint or wasp or
Michael schenecter group what the hell's
going on here and we went to this music
festival called Bourbon and Beyond down
in Kentucky and it was a huge huge venue
and
um they had like you know
um Brandy Carlisle and Pearl Jam and I
forget who else we saw there it was like
we were there for two two nights and it
was it was cool to see these bands but
the weird thing was there was there were
probably about like 150 000 maybe 200
200 000 people there and there was like
a like a river of people constantly
walking in front of of us we are in
grass seeds and we could see over them
so that wasn't a problem but you're like
where the hell are all these people
coming from and where the hell are they
all going you know and they were like
constantly circulating around and I I
think that's that there's there's
something going on there and I don't
really have my finger on it but a
restlessness an inability to like go to
a show where you're you know what what
is the purpose of the show you're there
to see the band to participate in the
audience experience not to just go off
and like I don't know
um buy merch at random times or you know
get your your eighth beer or you know
and that's a great point because going
to shows in the 80s and 90s or 2000s
early 2000s I didn't see that I mean I
see it a lot now and it's just yeah it's
it's crazy and people were like buying
buying drinks and stuff you know but you
would like do it at a certain time and
then you'd come back and sit your butt
down or stand up and you wouldn't really
I mean other than like trying to sneak
closer to the front you'd stay in your
place I also find it strange you know to
combine the the new album thing
I'm generally curious to hear the
artist's latest work
I saw sticks once and they had this
album Cyclorama I'll never forget JY
being very apologetic before they played
they played five songs from the album
which I think is good oh wow yeah he was
very apologetic okay just bear with us
we're gonna do another one from the
album with the carrot on the front and I
was most interested to hear that music
that night because
um of course I love the classics but I
want to hear you know
that's what you've turned we've talked
about being a Nostalgia band where your
set's the same for 25 years but right
right but a lot of people that's the
times people would just go to the
bathroom they don't want to hear the new
stuff and that's
that that didn't happen the Our
Generation didn't used to do that but I
see our generation doing that now that's
it it's not something we can blame on oh
with kids these days no proper
appreciation it's it's Gen X who are
like getting up and wandering off and
and you're like what the hell what's
with these people I mean and I don't do
that at concerts no when we get there we
sit we're gonna hear the whole thing
I'll admit I record stuff on my phone
yeah you know but um I'm not recording
like every single song because I
actually want to see with my own
eyeballs
what's going on up on stage you know so
but we I want to be uh respectful of
your time and we were going to talk a
bit more about the the mentoring thing
so why don't we close with that I was
very excited to see you posting about
this because knowing you as long as I
have
um it feels like kind of a natural
progression of your skills and talents
and and mindset to you know you've been
doing all these other things
um you've played on a lot of people's
work you've got your own albums you've
got
um you know a good practice as a gigging
and Studio musician as as somebody who's
teaching younger people but now this
idea of bringing it into like one-on-one
mentoring about how do you do well as a
musician that's kind of stepping it up I
think and so I'm curious how you why now
how did you arrive at doing that at this
point which I think by the way you're
perfectly well suited to to do this
thank you I think um
well really I think
I think studying the philosophy started
introducing something new to how I
taught so I for those of you that don't
know I I studied rhetoric in college
which I said was probably the best class
I studied because it protected me as a
musician in my 20s so um you know I
wasn't setting up syllogisms but I was
you know I was using a lot of the stuff
to go wait a minute you know and um I
thought I'd get back into it and I was
watching Greg's videos and I decided to
contact him we started with rhetoric and
what was happening is
I was already getting burnt out on just
teaching and what I you know what I mean
by just just teaching is you come in
um
you know you're working with the
fretboard and the in my case and the
mechanic or the theory
um and then
the the rhetoric started organizing my
thinking you know um so Aristotle didn't
tell me what to think but I we used to
take examples and I said well you know
this would be really useful for me and
you know I shouldn't hide it from my
students because this is actually and
actually a good point so what I found
over time was
there's a lot to be in an artist
um specifically with what I'm talking
about a lot to being an artist that goes
beyond the fretboard that goes beyond
um you know because there's hurdles
there's things there's obstacles that
get in our ways whether it's whether
it's envy and a lot of them are vices
that get in our way what's kind of an
emotional thing right
um you know indignant when I were you
know it meant something different back
then but that's how I use it you know
like
um actually being upset that somebody
has it you know a position you think you
deserve more well that's that's really
not helpful how do we we remove this
stuff yeah
um and it's it's not just about that
what I basically what it is is when
somebody's interested uh they they give
me kind of a list of their goals so I
did a few trial runs with with some
people I knew and I asked for feedback
but basically I said what is it you have
to have if you want to do the mentoring
program with me you have to have kind of
a Clear Vision yeah as opposed to
find the weaknesses in my plane and make
me better which which is fine yeah
um but I started using these tools in my
performance recital classes with
students
um because they would comment on music
if their peers were played that was
awesome
that's not much of a critique though
um
so you know getting into this kind of
this big you know thinking about stuff
um
and uh so with the trial I had a lot of
interesting things like one of the
people said one of their biggest things
was how do I not get depressed looking
at Instagram when everybody's doing so
much better yeah yeah
and I had to think about that one yeah
um you know I kind of came up with stuff
and then somebody else has asked you
know I want my career to take a new
Direction how do I make it that people
don't have me pigeonholed anymore that
is a big problem yeah yeah and um and
and so I'll usually ask what they're
after
and so far like anything that's been
asked I've been able to assist with
as far as you know and the teaching is
more conceptual in other words
instead of here's a C major scale I mean
that's important
but
um
pushing a creative part of maybe
organizing the pitches in there
Curiosity till the point where the
student says well can I do this of
course you could do that you just came
up with that I came up with that yeah
you came up with that that's yours you
know and um
so the the teaching music-wise is
conceptual and I think for the other
stuff it's just kind of like uh a lot of
it I am in tune with mindsets of people
I tend to be able to tell what's
holding them up because it's a lot of
stuff that held me up for years I mean
look all of this stuff yeah yeah I'm
still practicing you know I it would be
I wouldn't be a good Mentor if I said
I've got it all solved I'm I'm perfect
now and I'm going to show you my 10 top
secrets Yeah the secret because
you know and I'll say to the students
look I'm working on this too
every day it's not you know it's not a
Perfection it's a work in progress and
that's kind of the beauty of it yeah I
think that's something really uh
important it makes it you know instead
of like relating to the great Guru up
here on the Mountaintop it's it's
relating to somebody who's further along
in the path and can say yeah man I've
I've had some trouble with this I've
screwed up in the past myself and here's
how I you know here's here's the thing
to avoid that I did you know as a
knee-jerk reaction and here's how I I
got through it
um that lends a certain
relatability let's call it you know
which may motivate people better than
having the the guru who's you know never
screwed up in your in your back pocket
you know I think that's a good thing
because I I put up a video months ago
and um
a lot of one of the one of the people
said you know
I see all these people and they're like
oh you just jamming just you know
fidgeting around and it's a perfect take
and I you know I had to say look
more times than not that's not true you
know if you were to really ask that
person that might have been their 300th
take yeah
um or sometimes people like will lip
sync with their instruments I know that
but
um but what I did is I put up a video I
was working on a transcription of
pianist McCoy Tyner
and I got it up to Tempo and then I went
to record it
and I looked and I had like 12 takes
before I actually got it right and so
what I did is I cut up
the 12 takes where I just fall on my
face
you know all the way and I don't the
final one isn't even me doing it right
yeah and it's me like kind of cursing
damn it you know and like you know
um and then I put that up there for a
reason because it's it's kind of like
look you know I'm certainly far from
perfect I'm not gonna pretend to tell
you I did this in one take because I
didn't and I'm fine with that I don't it
doesn't make me feel less that you know
this thing I couldn't do in one take in
front of the camera so yeah it actually
doesn't matter
you know I've I've had something kind of
similar with my own uh videos where
quite often people don't know this
um I will I will start out talking and
then I'll be like nah that's not right
or I'll lose my train of thought or I'll
mispronounce something and I'm like all
right let's do it again you know and it
might be just one take and then I get it
right or it might be you know five or
six and usually by the end of fifth or
six I'm like damn it you know I'm
swearing and stuff like that and I have
taken some of those and put them as
outtakes for my
um Patron supporters that's cool yeah
and and people like it you know because
they're like yeah you know
um it's it's good to to realize that not
everybody gets it on exactly the first
take and as a matter of fact let's let's
bring this to a close by talking about a
different analogy coming from music but
also I think that can be tied in with
mentoring
so there's the like you know
takes issue but when you're playing
right if you screw up the worst thing
that you can do is to turn your screw up
into
um
something that becomes a crisis that
stops you like if you if you play the
wrong chord or something like that you
just keep on playing yeah and you don't
have to like pretend that everything was
was perfect or anything like that but
you do have to move on and I think that
in a lot of the problems that we have
people allow themselves to get
um stock something something happens
that they don't feel good about and then
it's like the end of the world you know
yeah
um that's true you know recovering from
um
like you know if we're talking about
performance yeah we used to you know I
had a big problem with that you know I
used to have panic attacks two nights
before a gig when I was you know in my
late teens early 20s
what if I screw up
yeah well
um it's par for the course you know it's
you know except you know when you do
like major more major gigs you know and
the band's rehearsing six eight hours a
day for 10 days that might be different
you really don't
want to screw up but you know if you're
doing pickup gigs or whatever or
improvising and going for something
the trick is to detach yourself from the
outcome and that's not there's no way to
do that there's not one way to do that
like you know it's not just say and do
that's that's short-sighted but um you
know
when I screw up now it's kind of like
you know and you know I I'll say that to
people you know when they perform for
their final I'm like I'm not deducting
by mistakes if the overall is
outstanding yeah
in one note you hit a wrong note or
misreaded something
then um
then that's fine if the overall was
cooked it's you know accidents right
accidents do happen and I've heard the
best of the best do it and um well they
didn't quit their instrument for it so I
think that's true I think it's
recovering from that stuff it was really
difficult for me but of course if three
different people came up to me and with
wanting to solve that we might get three
different answers because of the people
they are
that's right and I think that being able
to recover from mistakes is something
where
it's going to involve some creativity
yes but also structure at the same time
which is a nice way of circling back
so uh we're almost out of time is there
anything else that you wanted to bring
up or talk about briefly not really I
just you know I I just kind of launched
the program
um I did the post about a week or so ago
and um I'll be doing mostly posts on my
music page on Facebook and you know my
my Facebook page Instagram is a little
more difficult but um yeah I will be
putting kind of a flyer in it and uh
cool yeah you know like we'll put links
in in the video description to how to
find Scott and yeah yeah and I I'm just
I'm more excited for this because
I do enjoy mentoring more than
strictly just teaching because mentoring
is like more Hands-On it's more it's
more interesting to me and with people
and uh it's kind of like the how things
kind of changed and uh from my
perspective as I I get older and learn
and progress and I want to help people
do the same thing especially younger
talent that you know
it's early on in the road and you know
this stuff this stuff is really good no
matter what you plan on wanting to do at
least you may enjoy the journey
well that's good this is a great place
to leave off thanks so much for joining
me for this Scott uh happy to get you on
camera again you know and uh for a while
yeah well because we we haven't been
doing the the metal shows but maybe
we'll resume those sometime we can
resume those yeah absolutely all right
well that is where we're going to leave
off
um thanks to Scott for for all of this
and if you want to find out more about
him we'll put links in the video
description you just click show more and
all of that stuff will pop up